[Musique]
allez on allait c'est quoi ces festivals
ici on voit en plus moi je crois que tu
étais et un livre sans gluten
[Musique]
j'ai pas fait le temps dans l'épreuve
m
un petit salaire
[Musique]
1 2 3 verset calissi s'appelle d'aleris
berceau à la main gauche entre autres
vous êtes au courant qu'on ait le 16 du
mois
et alors quoi c'est moi c'est ça c'est
ça qu'on leur tienne pas du tout le
tabbee le sens c'est trop
comment n'est pas morte à mon nom j'ai
eu de la gueule un peu de la gueule tu
comprends
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine suivront la fin
tragique d'erwan un simple juniors sont
sans problème quoi bon jour est vrai on
n'est plus du jeu
[Musique]
condamnant au moins du mans au bout de
ma calage fera en tondeuse dans tâche
n'est qu'
[Musique]
on espère que tu as qui fait ce petit
bêtisier que tu harry comme nous avons
ri pendant tous ces tournages maintenant
nous t'invitons à t'abonner à la chaîne
golden moustache et a bien cliquer sur
la petite cloche parce que à la rentrée
on va revenir avec un sketch badass mon
pote je crois que t'es pas prêt alors
abonne toi et on se retrouve très
bientôt on vous fait des bisous les zhu
zhu feng shui